you're right Zed is weak um it is
intentional uh Zed must be kept weak
because he is the most frustrating
champion in League of Legends it's
official Zed is being kept intentionally
weak this is something that players have
long suspected Riot does to certain
Champs but since we heard it from an
official Riot Dev last week some players
have been up in
arms so Riot August is a lead designer
for League of Legends who over the years
has been responsible for a number of
iconic Champion designs and reworks if
you play VI Jinx Ekko Senna Vigo belv
Brier nard Zer or Jin then you have
August to thank the same goes for the
reworks of Rengar kale Janna tiia Morana
as well as parts of the reworks of JX
and wuk Kong to put it quite simply this
guy has been responsible for how tens of
millions of players play the game his
Twitter game is really strong too
whether he's posting self-deprecating
tweets about his Dev work or sharing a
lot of funny clips on Twitter of certain
fixes for Champions he's grown to be an
absolute fan favorite in the league
Community he is also someone that has
streamed quite a lot over the past few
years his stream has become a place
where he talks candidly about Kit
designs and any past or plan changes to
Champions and recently he shared
something pretty eye openening about one
champion in particular on stream Zed now
if you've been playing the game at all
this year you'll know that Zed has
become quite a problem in recent months
his ban rate was sitting at almost 40%
thanks in large part to big changes to
Assassin items Zed players were stacking
ability haste items abusing ravenous
Hydra and maxing W2 essentially turn him
into an ad Mage able to spam living
Shadow which made his laning phase
extremely uninteractive to play against
and his late game like trying to to grab
a fish with soapy hands what did I just
die to what the fck is that after some
Nerfs to dust blade and Zed's W some Zed
players felt the champion had been
gutted Beyond repair but everyone else
was quite happy to drink the tears of
Zed players after the champion had been
such a ubiquitous Menace in their game
for months and recently one of these
unhappy Zed players brought their
concerns directly to Riot August while
he was streaming maybe they thought he
would take pity on Zed maybe they
thought August would share some Zed
Buffs that Riot had planned but his
reply was far from that you're right Zed
is weak um it is intentional Zed must be
kept weak because he is the most
frustrating champion in League of
Legends and so for all of
eternity Zed will probably be slightly
weaker than he should be now look we've
all had our suspicions that Riot are
reluctant to tweak certain Champions
some of them are notoriously difficult
to balance maybe they're Ki or based
numbers are already so strong that any
minor changes Riot makes to their
abilities or the items that they usually
build causes them to become disgustingly
broken maybe buffing them to be good for
the average solo que player causes the
Esports scene to completely blow up
because Pros can maximize those Buffs to
the absolute extreme I'm looking at you
Yi but it's rare to hear a ryer say that
not only is the company aware that a
champion is weaker than it should be but
that it will stay that way for eternity
that's pretty heavy Grandmaster Zed
streamer Weeoo Slayer captured the shock
from zedmains who couldn't believe a
riot employee had admitted the company
intentionally keep Zed weaker he also
complained that Riot's determination to
reduce Zed banss in low ELO were making
it impossible for him to climb in Grand
Masters others felt Riot was being
straight up hypocritical here pointing
to Champions like Cante who has
undergone a bunch of changes in his
first year to address players issues
with him now I saw some people saying
this is because Cante is just a much
newer Champion Riot want to make things
work on these new releases that they
don't want new Champions to be poorly
balanced and then discarded by the
community for being too weak or because
Riot nerfed them to the ground perhaps
this iteration of Zed this concept we
have now is just unworkable another
thing that some Zed players have been
pushing back with is his win rates it's
been under 50% across all ranks for the
entire year so why is a champion that is
losing the majority of its games being
kept intentionally weak well one theory
is that Riot doesn't always balance
around win rates they balance around ban
rates sure it's not fun to get battered
by an absolutely broken Champion but
sometimes a champion is statistically
averaged by win rate but still
incredibly frustrating to play against
that frustration can manifest itself in
a number of different ways angry posts
on Reddit Twitter threads video rants
all of that can be quite hard to
quantify but ban rates are not in June
2019 Riot released a blog post in which
they outline their criteria for
balancing Champions it said that for the
bulk of players they aim to Nerf a
champion if they have an extremely high
win rate and a lower than average ban
rate stated by them to be around 7% or a
slightly high win rate coupled with a
ban rate five times the average by this
metric Zed is kind of technically
balanced he might not be perfect but he
doesn't meet the criteria for a buff or
a Nerf so is a lead developer right by
saying he is the most frustrating
champion in the game so one of the Zed's
issues is that he has unclear
counterplay to to um lower skilled
players in regards to what you're
supposed to do against him with his
laning pattern so for August it kind of
sounds like it's a skill issue similar
to the Yumi problem August feels that
Zed is simply a champion that low ELO
players just don't know how to play
against and he's saying that instead of
them learning how to counter Zed in and
out of Lane low ELO players are just
Banning him instead if that's true I
don't really think you can blame the
players that's that's kind of his whole
stick his whole kit is designed for him
to appear delete another player and then
just disappear kind of like a Carly for
a lot of people that is simply unfun and
uninteractive to play against and even
if he does mess up a combo he can always
just zip back to a distant Shadow when
Aus says Zed is the most frustrating
champion in the game he's saying they
simply don't like playing against him
regardless of his true strength uh you
look at it and it's actually got a lot
of counterplay which by the way makes
him weak in highr he ults you and then
there's like three for like you can run
away you can get shielded you can heal
etc etc etc but to a especially a low
MMR player who's getting aled by Zed the
experiences he ults me he
does he blinks away and then puts on his
sunglasses and goes cool guys don't look
at explosions and walks away and you
explode right and you're like that
wasn't fair and it's that sense of
fairness that I think is key here Zed
might not be the strongest champion in
the game but he feels unfair to play
against is this fixable August says that
Zed will never be buffed again but
surely this can't be the end of it I
think it's much more likely that Zed
players can expect a complete rework in
2024 or maybe with a power of ability
haste being reduced in season 14 Riot
might want to take another look at him
either way something needs to be done in
order to help the most frustrating
champion in the game I think if they do
end up changing Zed and they end up
reworking him people will look back at
that Faker clip Faker what was that and
be like what was this Champion how is
this a champion allowed in the game
that's crazy like it's the kind of
champion I think if if Z came out now
people wouldn't be happy people be like
what is this this looks insane